Bonjour à tous, aujourd'hui on va parler
d'une formule peu connue, mais qui fait pourtant
partie des équations les plus influentes
qui soit. Et pour une fois, non, on neva
pas parler de physique fondamentale, mais
de mathématiques financières, puisqu’il
s’agit de la formule de Black-Scholes.
La formule de Black-Scholes est une équation
qui, depuis les années 70, a profondément
transformé le secteur de la finance de marché,
et a donc eu un impact considérable sur l'économie
de ces dernières décennies. Un impact qui
se chiffre à l’heure actuelle en milliers
de milliards de dollars.
Aujourd'hui on va donc essayer de comprendre
ce qu'est cette mystérieuse formule, à quoi
elle sert, comment on l’établit. Et surtout
le lien fascinant qu'elle entretient avec
certains concepts essentiels de physique statistique.
[jingle]
Imaginons une situation complètement fictive.
Vous êtes boulanger, et l'ambassadeur du
coin vient vous commander 20 000 croissants
pour une réception. C'est une super opportunité
pour vous, vous lui faites un devis, qu'il
accepte. Seul point particulier : la réception
aura lieu dans un an. Oui, l’ambassadeur
est prévoyant.
Le problème c'est que vous ne pouvez pas
préparer dès maintenant les croissants pour
dans un an, il faudra le faire maximum quelques
jours avant. Sauf que vous avez déjà fixé
le prix sur votre devis, et peut-être que
d'ici un an, le coût des matières premières
nécessaires aura beaucoup changé.
Disons qu'actuellement la tonne de blé coûte
environ 200€.
[0 HISTORIQUE Mais vous savez que dans les
années passées, le cours du blé a varié,
et donc impossible de prévoir combien il
coûtera exactement dans un an. Si ça reste
autour de 200€, ça va aller. Mais si le
coût du blé augmente trop d'ici l’échéance,
comme vous avez déjà négocié le prix des
croissants, vous risquez fort de vous retrouver
avec une opération déficitaire. Ca serait
un peu embêtant !]
Vous décidez donc d'aller voir votre banque
pour trouver une solution, et celle-ci vous
propose une sorte d’assurance. Le prix actuel
du blé sur le marché est de 200€ la tonne;
eh bien si dans un an celui-ci a significativement
augmenté, et qu’il est supérieur à disons
220€, la banque s’engage à vous le fournir
quand même à 220€, pas plus. C'est plutôt
avantageux pour vous comme idée.
[1 SCENARIOS Voici l’historique du prix
sur l’année qui vient de s’écouler.
Si pour l’année à venir, le prix du blé
baisse sur le marché, tant mieux pour vous,
la matière première vous coûtera moins
cher que prévu. S’il augmente, mais qu'au
bout d’un an il est en-dessous de 220, vous
ferez moins de bénéfice avec vos croissants,
mais ça va encore.
En revanche si le prix du blé sur le marché
augmente fortement et dépasse 220, la banque
s’occupe de vous le fournir. Même si le
prix de marché est 250 voire 300 ou 400 euros
: peu importe, elle ne vous le fera payer
que 220€. Donc vous êtes couvert en cas
de hausse importante du prix du blé.]
Évidemment cette proposition a un coût,
rien n’est gratuit : vous allez devoir verser
dès maintenant une somme fixe à la banque,
afin de bénéficier de cette couverture.
C’est comme de payer une prime d'assurance.
Et la question cruciale est la suivante : combien
la banque doit-elle vous faire payer pour
ça ?
Vous trouvez peut-être cette question anecdotique,
mais il s’agit en fait d’un cas spécifique
d'un problème de finance extrêmement important
: celui de l'évaluation du prix des options,
ou pricing des options. Ce service d’assurance
financière que vous propose la banque avec
le blé, c'est en effet ce qu'on appelle une
option de type "call".
Une option call, c'est un contrat qu’on
achète en payant d’avance une prime fixe,
et qui offre la possibilité d'acheter un
produit à une certaine date dans le futur,
mais à un prix fixé d’avance. Ici le contrat
était pour une tonne de blé dans un an,
et le prix fixé d'avance c'était 220€.
C’est ce qu’on appelle le prix d'exercice
de l’option.
[2 CALL Si quand on arrive à la date donnée,
le cours du produit sur le marché est supérieur
au prix d'exercice, le bénéficiaire va en
général décider d'exercer l'option. C'est-à-dire
qu’il demande à la banque qui lui a vendu
l'option d’honorer son engagement, et donc
de lui vendre le produit au prix d'exercice.
Ici la banque sera obligée contractuellement
de vendre une tonne de blé au boulanger pour
220€, et ce quel que soit le cours du blé
sur le marché.
Mais si le cours du blé sur le marché est
inférieur à 220€, là le boulanger a intérêt
à acheter sur le marché et à ne pas exercer
l'option. L’option va simplement expirer,
un peu comme une assurance qui n'aurait servi
à rien.
Une option call, c’est un droit d’acheter
à une certaine date à un certain prix, mais
ça n'est pas une obligation. Le détenteur
est libre d'exercer ou pas l'option, et donc
de se rendre acquéreur ou pas. C’est pour
ça qu’on appelle ça une «option».]
A l'opposé de ces options "call", il existe
des options qu'on appelle "put", et qui permettent
cette fois de faire l’inverse : de vendre
un produit à une certaine date, et à un
prix fixé à l'avance. Et là le même principe
s’applique.
[2 PUT Si le prix de marché est inférieur
au prix d'exercice, le détenteur aura intérêt
à exercer l'option pour écouler son produit
à un prix plus avantageux que s'il vendait
sur le marché. Ca permet par exemple de s'assurer
contre une baisse des prix, si on sait qu'on
aura une marchandise à écouler à une date
future.
Et si le prix de marché est resté supérieur
au prix de l’option, le détenteur vendra
sur le marché sans exercer l’option.]
Il existe encore d'autres types d'options,
et de façon générale, celles-ci ne portent
pas que sur les matières premières, comme
le blé, mais peuvent aussi porter sur des
devises ou des actions. Le produit sur lequel
porte l’option s’appelle l’actif sous-jacent.
Et se procurer des options, c’est une manière
pour l’acquéreur de l’option de faire
face aux incertitudes, et de se couvrir face
aux éventuels risques de fluctuations imprévisibles
des cours, ou des taux de change.
Et donc la grande question que l'on s'est
posée dans le cas du blé, c'est : comment
fixer le juste prix d'une option ? Comment
la banque, ou l'institution financière qui
va émettre l’option, peut-elle décider
de la valeur de cette option ? Pour déterminer
cela, on peut déjà se demander combien ça
va lui coûter quand il faudra honorer son
engagement.
Pour faire simple, imaginons pour commencer
qu'on ne parle pas d’une option financière,
mais plutôt d'une assurance incendie sur
un logement. Comment calculer le coût d’une
assurance, ce qu’il faudra débourser pour
couvrir l’éventuel sinistre ?
[3 INCENDIE Pour ça, on peut estimer la probabilité
qu’un incendie se produise dans le logement
concerné au cours de l’année, disons 0.1%.
Puis on peut regarder la valeur du logement,
disons 100 000 euros.
Dans 99.9% des cas le logement ne brulera
pas et ça coûtera 0 à la banque. Dans 0.1%
des cas il faudra rembourser le logement et
ça coûtera 100 000 euros. Et donc en moyenne,
ça coûtera 0.1% fois 100 000 c’est à
dire 100 euros par logement assuré.
Ce raisonnement en moyenne montre combien
cela va coûter à la banque de fournir ce
contrat d’assurance. Si la banque le fait
avec un grand nombre de clients et de logements,
elle peut s’autoriser ce raisonnement «en
moyenne» comme base pour fixer la valeur
de la prime d’assurance.]
Ca c’était pour un risque d’incendie,
mais revenons au cas d’une option call sur
par exemple le prix du blé. C'est plus compliqué
car ce n’est pas binaire comme l’incendie
que j’ai imaginé. Il peut se passer différentes
choses.
[4 COÛT Si à échéance le cours du blé
est inférieur au prix d’exercice de 220€,
l’option ne coûtera rien à la banque,
puisque son détenteur n’aura aucun intérêt
à l’exercer.
Mais si le cours du blé termine au dessus
de 220€ et que le détenteur exerce l’option,
la banque sera contrainte de lui vendre une
tonne de blé à 220€, donc à un prix inférieur
à celui du marché. Si la banque se procure
la tonne sur le marché, cela lui coûtera
la différence entre les deux : et donc d’autant
plus cher que le cours dépasse 220€.
Pour estimer le coût moyen de l’option
pour la banque, il faut donc pouvoir tenir
compte de tous les scénarios possibles.]
Pour ça, regardons déjà comment le cours
du blé a varié par le passé.
[5 HISTORIQUE Imaginons qu'il ait en gros
cette allure-ci sur les 5 dernières années.
Ces variations ont l'air essentiellement aléatoires,
donc impossible de savoir avec certitude ce
qu'il adviendra dans l’année à venir.]
L’évolution d’un cours de bourse est
par nature imprédictible, et c’est ce que
mathématiquement on appelle un processus
stochastique. Parfois ça monte, parfois ça
descend, sans logique apparente. Et ça ressemble
beaucoup à ce qu’on appelle en physique,
un mouvement brownien.
[jingle]
Le mouvement brownien, cela désigne à l’origine
le mouvement, en apparence totalement aléatoire,
que subissent des petites particules immergées
dans un fluide. Il a été décrit pour la
première fois en 1827 par Robert Brown, alors
qu’il observait au microscope des grains
de pollen dans l’eau.
En 1905, Albert Einstein en a fourni une description
théorique, en proposant que ce mouvement
erratique soit dû aux collisions aléatoires
des molécules d’eau avec les particules
en suspension. Une interprétation confirmée
quelques années plus tard par les expériences
du français Jean Perrin, ce qui a permis
de donner du crédit à l’idée que la matière
était faite d’atomes et de molécules,
et qui a valu à Jean Perrin le prix Nobel
en 1926.
[MICROSCOPE Ici j’ai tenté une petite mise
en évidence expérimentale du mouvement brownien
avec du lait observé au microscope. Et les
particules que l’on distingue sont de minuscules
gouttelettes de graisse et de protéines en
suspension. On voit bien leur mouvement erratique.]
Le modèle mathématique le plus simple du
mouvement brownien, c’est celui dit de la
marche aléatoire.
[6 WALK Par exemple en 2 dimensions, on imagine
qu’une particule donnée se trouve dans
une des cases d’une grille, et qu’à chaque
instant, la particule saute sur une des cases
voisines tirée au hasard. Une chance sur
4 d’aller au-dessus, 1 chance sur 4 d’aller
en-dessous, et pareil à droite et à gauche.
Avec ce genre de modèle très simple, la
particule suit une trajectoire complètement
erratique qu’on appelle donc une marche
aléatoire. On voit que plus le temps passe,
plus la particule semble se balader loin,
mais en revenant parfois et en restant en
moyenne autour de sa position initiale.]
Avec une seule particule, on ne comprend pas
forcément ce qu’il se passe, mais imaginons
que j’en dépose un très grand nombre au
centre, et que chacune suive sa trajectoire
en marché aléatoire.
[7 WALK MANY On voit qu’il se forme comme
une tâche qui s’étale, et c’est exactement
ce qu’il se passerait si on déposait par
exemple une goutte de colorant au milieu de
l’eau. Sur un grand nombre de particules,
la marche aléatoire reproduit un phénomène
de diffusion.]
Là vous allez me dire : c’est très joli
mais quel rapport avec la finance et les options
? Eh bien on vient de voir un mouvement brownien
en 2 dimensions, mais les cours de bourse
ressemblent beaucoup à des mouvements brownien
en 1 dimension.
A chaque instant, un cours de bourse sur un
actif donné va monter ou descendre, et ce
de façon en apparence imprédictible, comme
les petits sauts de ma particule. On peut
essayer d’en faire un modèle simple.
[8 VOLATILITE Imaginons que chaque jour de
cotation à la bourse, le cours du blé monte
ou descende de 0.2€, à une chance sur 2.
On peut simuler une trajectoire possible pour
l’année entière à venir, et même plein
de trajectoires différentes, puisqu’il
y a une composante de hasard.
Ca a l’air pas mal mais on voit que ça
ne colle pas avec l’historique, ça varie
bien trop peu. C’est parce que des sauts
de 0.2€ par jour, ça n’est pas assez.
On peut regarder avec 0.5€, 1€ voire 5€.
On voit que l’amplitude générale colle
plutôt pas mal avec des sauts de 1€.
Cette valeur qui représente la taille typique
des sauts, c’est ce qu’on appelle la volatilité,
et c’est quelque chose qui va dépendre
du cours qu’on considère, mais qu’on
peut mesurer en utilisant un historique des
cours passés.]
Malgré tout, ce modèle où le cours fait
un petit saut fixe à chaque instant est quand
même un peu trop simpliste. On le voit bien
sur les courbes qui ont des dents de scie,
et on sait qu’en pratique la taille des
sauts qu’on observe peut varier d’une
fois sur l’autre.
Plutôt que quelque chose de binaire qui monte
ou qui descend d’une valeur fixe, on peut
imaginer par exemple que la taille des sauts
suive une distribution gaussienne.
[9 GAUSSIENNE La majorité du temps les sauts
seront petits, en positif ou en négatif,
et de temps en temps ils seront plus extrêmes.
C’est le genre de variation qu’on constate
en pratique sur les vrais cours de bourse.
Et la largeur de la gaussienne, son écart-type,
représente la volatilité du cours.]
Et même encore mieux, on peut essayer de
raisonner non pas sur les variations absolues,
en euros ou en dollars, mais sur les variations
en pourcentage, qui sont plus représentatives.
Ce sont d’ailleurs des pourcentages qui
sont toujours rapportés dans les infos boursières.
Le modèle mathématique qu’on obtient alors
s’appelle un mouvement brownien géométrique,
et c’est la description typique que l’on
utilise quand on veut modéliser un cours
de bourse par un processus stochastique.
Avec ce modèle, si on est capable d’estimer
la volatilité à partir d’un historique
du cours, on peut simuler plein d’évolutions
possibles et crédibles de ce cours. Et donc
créer des scénarios pour essayer de calculer
le juste prix de notre option.
Voici comment on peut procéder : on utilise
le modèle du mouvement brownien pour simuler
une évolution possible du cours du blé.
On regarde au bout d’un an combien cela
va coûter à la banque, en fonction de si
ça a dépassé ou pas le prix d’exercice.
Et puis on recommence, des milliers de fois.
Et on fait la moyenne.
On trouvera alors le coût moyen de l’option
pour la banque, ce que ça lui coûtera en
moyenne d’honorer sa part du contrat. On
peut appeler cela le juste prix, si on veut,
même si en pratique le vrai prix sera plus
élevé pour tenir compte des frais, du bénéfice,
etc. Mais ce prix théorique permet de donner
une référence.
Ici si on fait ces simulations avec disons
1 million de trajectoires possibles et un
prix d’exercice de 220€, on trouve une
valeur moyenne d’environ 8.5€. Ca représente
le prix de référence de l’option qu’a
proposé la banque à notre boulanger.
Evidemment, le prix de l’option sera différent
si on change le prix d’exercice. Si le prix
d’exercice est plus élevé, disons 240€,
l’option sera moins chère, environ seulement
4€.
[10 COURBE On peut même tracer la courbe
du prix de l’option en fonction du prix
d’exercice, et c’est une courbe décroissante.
C’est logique que ça varie comme ça. Si
le prix d’exercice est plus élevé, il
y a moins de chance que le cours du blé atteigne
cette valeur, donc moins de chance que l’option
soit exercée. Donc ça coûte moins cher.
Inversement avec un prix d’exercice plus
bas, le prix de l’option sera plus élevé
car elle a plus de chance de servir et donc
de coûter de l’argent à la banque qui
l’a émise.]
Le prix de l’option va aussi dépendre du
temps qui nous sépare de la date d’effet.
Ici on a pris l’exemple d’un an. Mais
si on prend 6 mois le prix de l’option sera
plus faible, il y a moins de risque de forte
variation en 6 mois qu’en un an. Et si on
prend 2 ans ce sera l’inverse.
En pratique c’est d’ailleurs rare que
les options portent sur une durée si longue,
la durée typique c’est plutôt quelques
semaines ou quelques mois.
La méthode qu’on a utilisée ici, simuler
plein de cours possibles et estimer ainsi
le prix de l’option, c’est une méthode
qu’on appelle parfois «Monte-Carlo».
C’est le nom générique qu’on donne à
tout un tas de méthodes qui font intervenir
des simulations d’un processus aléatoire.
Ca marche bien mais c’est un peu fastidieux
: ici c’était un cas simple et j’ai simulé
un million de trajectoires. C’est facile
avec un ordinateur moderne, mais il y a 50
ans c’était beaucoup moins faisable. Et
c’est dans ce contexte qu’en 1973 a été
publié une formule qui permet d’avoir directement
la réponse sans faire ce genre de simulations
: la fameuse formule de Black et Scholes.
[jingle]
La formule dont on va parler est basée sur
un modèle qui est donc dû aux économistes
Fischer Black et Myron Scholes, qui l’auraient
mise au point à la fin des années 70, mais
publiée seulement en 1973, en même temps
qu’un autre économiste : Robert Merton.
Pour démontrer leur formule, ils ont raisonné
sur la stratégie que peut mettre en place
la banque, ou l’institution qui a créé
et vendu l’option.
[ATTENTISME On l’a dit, la méthode de calcul
Monte Carlo permet d’estimer le «juste
prix» de l’option, mais en supposant
que la banque a une sorte de stratégie attentiste
: elle attend l’échéance, et en fonction
du prix du marché de l’actif par rapport
au prix d’exercice, cela va lui coûter
plus ou moins cher d’honorer le contrat.]
En moyenne, sur plein de situations différentes,
cela lui coûtera ce «juste prix» qu’on
a calculé. Mais d’une fois sur l’autre,
ce sera très différent : parfois ça ne
lui coutera rien, parfois ça lui coutera
beaucoup, si le cours termine avec un prix
très différent du prix d’exercice.
L’inconvénient de cette stratégie attentiste,
c’est qu’elle génère de l’incertitude
pour la banque. Parfois elle sera bénéficiaire,
parfois elle sera déficitaire, il y a une
grosse part de hasard, ce que les banques
n’aiment pas trop.
Or Black et Scholes ont montré qu’en adoptant
une certaine stratégie d’investissement,
moins attentiste, la banque pouvait, au moins
en théorie, éliminer cette incertitude.
C’est-à-dire faire en sorte que quelle
que soit l’évolution du cours de bourse,
cela lui coûte exactement la même chose
de fournir le service : plus de hasard.
[DELTA NEUTRE L’idée est la suivante : quand
l’option est vendue, la banque collecte
la prime et va investir en partie dans l’actif
concerné. Ici imaginons qu’elle achète
du blé, mais pas forcément une tonne complète.
Et ensuite au fur et à mesure que le cours
change, elle va de façon continue ajuster
la quantité qu’elle possède.
Plus le cours augmente, plus elle devra en
posséder afin de fournir le blé à échéance
en cas d’exercice de l’option. Et inversement
elle en conservera de moins en moins si le
prix descend.]
Et Black et Scholes ont montré qu’il existe
une stratégie optimale de couverture en continu,
qui élimine le hasard et l’incertitude.
Cette stratégie porte un nom technique : ça
s’appelle la couverture en delta neutre.
Et nos deux économistes ont démontré qu’en
suivant cette stratégie optimale qui élimine
l’incertitude, le juste prix de l’option
obéit à une certaine équation différentielle
que vous pouvez voir ici.
[11 ED Les équations différentielles, ce
sont des équations qui portent sur les fonctions,
et qu’on croise généralement plutôt en
physique, pour modéliser l’électromagnétisme,
la mécanique des fluides ou encore les transferts
de chaleur.
Et d’ailleurs l’équation établie par
Black et Scholes ressemble assez fortement
aux équations de diffusion de la chaleur.
Ils ont alors montré qu’on pouvait résoudre
de façon exacte cette équation différentielle,
et en tirer une formule qui donne directement
le juste prix des options, en fonction de
la volatilité des cours, du prix d’exercice
et du temps avant la date d’exercice.]
Et donc sans faire aucune simulation Monte-Carlo
ou aucun calcul fastidieux, il est possible
de déterminer le juste prix de tout un tas
d’options, sur à peu près n’importe
quel type de cours, quel que soit l’actif
sous-jacent concerné.
Tout à l’heure quand on évoquait l’évolution
des cours, je vous ai parlé de mouvement
brownien, et je l’ai illustré avec l’image
de particules qui diffusent dans de l’eau.
Et maintenant on parle du juste prix des options
et on se retrouve avec une équation différentielle
qui ressemble à l’équation de la chaleur.
Ca n’est pas un hasard, il y a un lien profond
entre les deux.
Quand on parle de la diffusion de la chaleur,
on peut adopter deux points de vues complémentaires.
Soit un point de vue «microscopique»,
où on imagine des petits paquets d’énergie
qui sautent aléatoirement à droite ou à
gauche.
[12 MICRO MACRO Soit un point de vue macroscopique
où on considère par exemple la température
d’un objet en tout point, et on regarde
comment cette température évolue globalement
dans l’espace et dans le temps, en utilisant
une équation différentielle.]
D’un côté on a un processus microscopique
stochastique, de l’autre côté une évolution
macroscopique déterministe régie par une
équation différentielle. Eh bien il se passe
la même chose avec les cours de bourse et
les prix des options. Et c’est un cas particulier
d’une relation plus profonde mise en évidence
par le physicien Richard Feynman et le mathématicien
Robert Kac.
L’anecdote raconte que Feynman et Kac travaillaient
tous les deux à l’université de Cornell
aux Etats Unis, chacun dans son département.
Et qu’un jour Kac est allé à un séminaire
de Feynman où celui-ci présentait son approche
de la mécanique quantique à partir de ce
qu’on appelle les intégrales de chemin.
Kac s’est alors rendu compte que Feynman
et lui travaillaient en fait sur le même
sujet mais de deux points de vue différents.
Ils ont alors combiné leurs idées et ont
pu démontrer un résultat général fascinant
: pour toute une famille d’équations différentielles,
comme l’équation de la chaleur, il est
possible d’obtenir une solution en simulant
un certain processus stochastique.
Il aura fallu 20 ans de plus pour que cette
correspondance mystérieuse soit reconnue
et appliquée aux mathématiques financières,
mais d’une certaine manière la formule
de Black-Scholes peut être vue comme une
déclinaison de la formule de Feynman-Kac.
[jingle]
Depuis sa publication en 1973, la formule
de Black-Scholes a eu un impact considérable
sur la finance de marché. En permettant de
fixer correctement le prix d’options portant
sur tous types de produits financiers, elle
a rendu possible le développement de toute
l’ingénierie financière autour de ce qu’on
appelle les produits dérivés.
Car je vous ai parlé ici d’options qui
permettaient d’acheter des matières premières
ou des devises. Mais grâce à la formule
de Black-Scholes, on peut émettre et fixer
le prix d’options sur quasiment tout et
n’importe quoi dont le cours fluctue : comme
des actions, voire même d’autres options.
Oui oui, des options sur des options.
D’ailleurs je vous ai présenté les options
comme une sorte d’instrument d’assurance,
qui permet à certains acteurs économiques
de réduire leur exposition à des incertitudes.
C’est un usage qui existe toujours aujourd’hui,
mais les options sont aussi surtout utilisées
à des fins de spéculation.
Imaginez : vous pensez que le cours du blé
va monter, vous en êtes convaincus parce
que vous avez fait une analyse de ce marché
qui vous fait penser ça. Une chose possible
pour spéculer grâce à votre idée, c’est
d’acheter du blé, et de le revendre s’il
monte. Mais une autre possibilité, c’est
d’acheter une option call.
Si à échéance le prix du blé a effectivement
monté comme vous l’aviez prédit, vous
exercez votre option : vous achetez le blé
pas cher grâce à elle, et vous le revendez
immédiatement au prix du marché en empochant
la différence.
Et là pas besoin d’être boulanger ou quoi
que ce soit, vous utilisez simplement l’option
pour faire un pari à la hausse, et jamais
vous n’entrez en possession physique du
moindre grain de blé.
Inversement vous pouvez utiliser les options
put pour faire des paris à la baisse. Si
vous pensez que le cours du blé va s’effondrer,
vous achetez des options put qui vous permettront
de faire l’inverse : si vous aviez raison,
à échéance de l’option vous acheterez
au prix du marché, donc pas cher, et vous
revendrez immédiatement au prix d’exercice
de l’option.
Ca peut paraitre un peu bizarre d’utiliser
ce mécanisme d’option juste à cette fin.
Si on voit l’option comme un mécanisme
d’assurance, spéculer avec c’est comme
de prendre une assurance sur un truc que vous
ne possédez pas.
Supposez : vous avez remarqué que votre voisin
conduit très mal. Vous vous dites qu’il
va finir par avoir un accident, et pour essayer
de tirer un bénéfice de ça, vous décidez
de prendre une assurance sur *sa* voiture.
Evidemment en vrai on peut pas faire ça,
heureusement, mais imaginez. Si je suis assuré
contre les accidents de mon voisin, ben j’ai
tout intérêt à ce qu’il se plante. Je
m’assure contre un risque que je ne cours
pas personnellement. Je vais donc espérer
qu’il se crache pour toucher l’argent
de l’assurance.
Eh bien ce qu’il n’est pas possible de
faire avec une assurance auto ou logement,
on peut d’une certaine façon le faire avec
les risques financiers, en jouant avec des
options portant sur des risques auxquels on
n’est pas forcément exposés, juste par
spéculation.
En rendant simple et mathématique la question
complexe du pricing des options, la formule
de Black-Scholes a permis ce type de montage
à des échelles vertigineuses. On estime
en effet que le montant total couvert par
les options en circulation dans le monde serait
aujourd’hui d’environ 600 000 milliards
de dollars.
Bien évidemment, la formule de Black-Scholes
a aussi mené à des excès. Et il n’est
pas rare que même les financiers chevronnés
se plaignent de son rôle dans certaines crises
financières et de son utilisation abusive.
Comme a pu le faire par exemple le célèbre
investisseur Warren Buffet.
On peut aussi évoquer la retentissante faillite
du fond d’investissement Long-Term Capital
Management, un fond pourtant cofondé par
Merton et Scholes, deux des découvreurs de
la formule. Et ironiquement, leur fond s’est
effondré un an après que ces derniers aient
reçu le prix Nobel d’économie pour leurs
travaux sur la fameuse équation.
Il ne faut en effet pas oublier que comme
tout modèle mathématique, la formule de
Black-Scholes repose sur certaines hypothèses
assez contraignantes, et qui portent sur l’évolution
stochastique des cours.
J’ai évoqué notamment l’hypothèse du
mouvement brownien géométrique, dont on
sait qu’elle n’est pas rigoureusement
exacte, et qu’elle néglige notamment certaines
fluctuations de grande ampleur. Des fortes
hausses ou baisses, dont on sait qu’elles
se produisent parfois, même si elle ne devraient
pas arriver si l’hypothèse du mouvement
brownien géométrique était parfaitement
correcte.
Ce sont ces événements extrêmes que l’économiste
Nassim Taleb appelle les cygnes noirs, et
j’en avais d’ailleurs parlé dans ma vidéo
qui comparait les tremblements de terre aux
crachs boursiers, un autre bel exemple de
correspondance entre finance et physique.
Vous pouvez aller la voir si le sujet vous
intéresse.
Voilà c’est tout pour aujourd’hui, n’oubliez
pas de vous abonner si ça n’est pas déjà
le cas. Je rappelle que cette vidéo n’est
pas un cours de maths financières et encore
moins un tutoriel d’investissement donc
ne faites pas n’importe quoi.
Merci à Gilles de la chaine Heureka, qui
a gentiment accepté de relire mon script,
vous pouvez allez voir sa chaîne et notamment
la série de vidéo qu’il a consacré à
la faillite du fond Long Term Capital Management
dont j’ai parlé.
Pour prolonger la discussion n’hésitez
pas à venir sur le discord de science étonnante,
le lien est en description, et moi je vous
retrouve très vite pour une nouvelle vidéo.
A bientôt.